[Music]
most people have uh
almost you know ward cleaver
type values and worlds that they move in
very comfortably
cyberspace gene therapy
virtual reality nanotechnology
interstellar travel life extension
these things enliven the experience of
reading the newspaper
but they don't come tangential
to most people's lives on the other hand
you know some people the technical
community that's creating
these things the the cadres of media
people who must understand and
re-explain this stuff
back to the general public
they breathe and eat
this stuff and and some people
like myself i guess are ambivalent
go between between it
uh what's you know
human beings have always existed
sociologically and
aesthetically and conventionally over a
much broader
spectrum of behaviors and attitudes
than any other species we're familiar
with
but that difference
has undergone like a hyper inflationary
explosion
in the last 15 years
largely because well no there are so
many reasons
you know gender redefinition the rise of
the internet the emergence of the super
rich the emergence of the super
poor the emergence of the totally wired
the emergence of the totally
disconnected
and also the awareness that
this the growing sophistication of
propaganda
which makes all honest efforts to
establish a level playing field of
discourse
easily subverted i mean
every time you think you're having an
honest
discussion or making an honest appraisal
of a situation
if you pull back one level you discover
you're
you're embedded in other people's
agendas
and other people's and institutions
styles of manipulating
reality i mentioned to you eric davis's
book
uh it hasn't come out yet technosis when
it does come out i
urge you to read it for all kinds of
reasons
one i would mention here is that it
showed me
that everyone
including myself and that is the big
shock for me
is a creature of their time and that
it's
very hard not to
serve invisible agendas
where you know you you don't realize
that you
think the way you think for reasons
entirely
divorced from who you are where you are
and what's good for you
for example you know in the middle ages
christian piety permeated every level of
society and every act
and every thought even knows the critics
of christian piety it wasn't that there
were people who stood apart from it
if you defined yourself by attacking it
you nevertheless were defined by it
i think i mentioned recently or
somewhere or
some time that back when i was a student
at berkeley
once during a riot people dropped a
banner off
a third floor dorm
balcony that said
it was a quote from jean-paul satra we
cannot transcend marxism
until we transcend the conditions that
have created it
and in a way uh we cannot transcend
the social political and philosophical
reality
that we are now very uncomfortably
situated in until we transcend
the conditions that created but we are
those conditions the momentum of our
ideologies is the main thing holding
together the illusion of any coherency
at all
i mean the people who are really
with it are really difficult to
understand
and their the their effort
to communicate is is
maddeningly unsuccessful i think
for them and for us the the
balkanization of discourse the
proliferation of special vocabularies
the generation of
uh unstated professional assumptions
the we all know kind of
sense of reality out of which then
statements
can be made tends to island
discourse and yet if discourse is
islanded
community becomes nearly
uh impossible well is that a good
thing or a bad thing i don't know
that seems to me you know the
conclusions that we've
drawn from the uh
these meetings that we've had which
themselves
have been plagued by this kind of
fragmentation
and dissipation i mean people have
seldom christ things to do
they have processing to do they
have to meet their connection they have
something else
to do that busts up their loyalty to
even the idea
of six consecutive meetings on the
subject of chaos
um
[Laughter]
yes no we're living it but you know the
important thing is to realize that
you're living it and that that's what it
is you know
what i my what i come away from all this
with
is that looking at the future
of which is already in place i mean
don't imagine
that you know the world will look
greatly different
in five or ten years it may look
slightly different
this world we're living in the world of
1998
to the camera's eye is indistinguishable
from the world of 1990
and yet you know the most elaborate and
sophisticated technical
artifact in the history of mankind has
been put in place
in those eight years the rise of the
internet
but you know who runs into it who
stumbles over it who sees it it's
odorless tasteless
invisible we all had computers in 1990
it's simply that they were
large paperweights now they have become
telepathic creatures and while we
matter over the implications of all of
this
they freely converse with each other in
a planetary wide environment
and evolve themselves toward you know
whatever destiny lies in wait for the
machine
logos that that we have pulled into
existence
so this future which is already here
has implications that not that few of us
have fully grocked i think and i
i listed three of them just to as a crib
to help me through this first of all
that there is no
closure all ideology
is now exposed as an adolescent
response to being you know we
if the 20th century taught us anything
it taught us the toxic
nature of ideology the excesses of the
left
led to the holocaust the excesses of the
right
led to the the pogroms and mass trials
of stalinist russia the excesses of the
cultural revolution
in china the suppression of
descent
in many parts of the world so uh there
there is a need to abandon ideology
which is really a postmodern position
and it's very uncomfortable the absence
of
closure is a post-juvenile
stance toward being that few
people in the past ever lived long
enough
to grow comfortable with
you know if you died at age 40 culture
as a con game lasts long enough
to keep you entranced until
sometime in mid life if you live
beyond midlife and you still are
fascinated and entranced by culture
chances are you're an idiot
i mean is this not
obvious you know i mean after the
this is why i mean marketing has
shrewdly understood this
this is why we are folded back toward
the idolization of youth
because it's an idolization of
cluelessness
you know it's not the firm body and the
quick step
that the marketers are interested to
sell you
it's innocence but
innocence are people you love to play
poker with if you
are sufficiently cynical and believe me
the market forces are sufficiently
cynical
so uh assimilating to the future means
living
not with no ideology
whatsoever or with uh
and people say well can one live without
ideologies
isn't the belief we should uh um
you know strive for peace and justice
and
ideology i don't think so i think these
are provisional models of
behaviors that derive from
immediate practical concerns that can be
revised in real time
constantly held up to the incoming flow
of data
and adjusted that's why the concept
model
is somewhat you know if lennon had said
he had a model
if hitler had said he had a model i
think
it would have played out with the more
soft conclusions
than to say you know a new truth
is proclaimed and the behaviors which
derive from it are
incontrovertible so
no no ideological closure
and i don't know how you feel about this
i'm
very comfortable with it i i
was passionate about ideology and my
youth i've had
most of them you know at 11
i was reading mein kampf and feshton
europa
sound like a very good idea i loved all
that
pseudo-egyptian over scale tasteless
architecture and all that stuff folk
dancing
and summer camping sounded attractive
at 17 i was a marxist
you know ready to go to the barricades
for the workers state
at 22 we marched under the black flag of
anarchy
used to bust up meetings of trotskyites
and
write graffiti on their front doors and
make life hell
for those people now i don't give a [ __ ]
and i feel much better about it
thank you uh i mean i think we should
try strive for a sane and caring world
that gives as many people as much choice
to express themselves as possible beyond
that
i don't feel any kind of an imperative
[Music]
you